[Musik]
so ihr dachtet also ihr könnt als
Lehrerzimmer einmarschieren und auch so
verkackten Klausuren auslöschen tja ich
merke schon eure Militärstrategie ist
mangelhaft und deshalb ist unser
heutiges nachsitzthema
die einzige Institution die noch größere
Materialprobleme hat als diese Schule
die Deutsche Bahn die Bundeswehr
also
das Jahr 1945 die Welt teilt sich in
zwei Hälften und ich rede jetzt nicht
von wie das gegen Stones weil die Videos
waren einfach für uns
okay die Welt teilt sich in Ost und West
und unter dem Eindruck dieses Kalten
Krieges er hält die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland 10 Jahre nach Weltkriegsende
eine neue Armee und die beginnt mit der
Ernennung von 101 freiwilligen Soldaten
ja erstmal wenig aber die werden
zumindest 1A rausgeputzt der Arbeit
Anzug für Herr und Luftwaffe eine
zweiteilige Kombination aus leichtem
Baumwollstoff schicke Outfits hin oder
her bald stellt sich heraus so viele
Leute gibt's gar nicht die ihr
Nachkriegs Deutschland Lust auf Dienst
an der Waffe haben und deshalb heißt es
für junge Männer in der BRD schon
1956 du musst zur Bundeswehr
die Bundeswehr so heißt die Truppe jetzt
fühlt die wirklich ein sowas könnt ihr
Flachpfeifen euch gar nicht mehr
vorstellen
jeder junge Mann muss für eine
ultimative Mobbing prozedon namens
Musterung durchlaufen nackt ausziehen in
einen Becher pinkeln und dann der EKG
der
eierkontrollen zwei Finger an die
Kronjuwelen und dann
und wenn das geschafft hatte der dufte
bis zu 18 Monate in einer damalige
Kaserne umziehen und da Hundefutter
Wanzen und naja zwischendurch auf Stube
und für den Verteidigungsfall drin
[Musik]
genug Personal hatte die Armee jetzt
dafür gab es bei der Ausrüstung Probleme
unter Franz-Josef Strauß das ist der
Mann hier Herr an der Kinderzimmer waren
von Markus Söder macht die Bundeswehr
Schlagzeilen mit dubiosen Deals rund um
schrottiges darf weiter Flugzeugen aber
es ist eigentlich auch egal denn richtig
zu tun kriegt die Bundeswehr eh erst
Ende der 90er Jahre bei ihrem ersten
militärischen Auslandseinsatz im Kosovo
angeordnet für diese Einsatz von Gerhard
Schröder ihr kennt den von Instagram
echt nicht mehr nach Krieg aus und so
dürfen ab 2011
[Musik]
in New York ich war noch die Wahl den
sollten wir mal zum ESC schicken
egal
2011 wandelt Karl-Theodor zu Guttenberg
die Bundeswehr als Sparmaßnahme in eine
freiwilligen Armee um eventuell ein
Fehler wenn man die Bewerber anschaut
Fernglas Weg erst zuhören
umschlaggruppe 2 NVG EVG verstanden
kein Wort
kann ich mal die Waffe haben nein die
Bundeswehr verliert zwar Mitglieder aber
nicht als Skandal Potenzial z.B taucht
in unschöne Regelmäßigkeit Personal auf
das na ja in seiner Weltanschauung mehr
rechts 3 hat als ein kaputtes G36 Gewehr
und apropos zu den nazis-skandalen
kommen mal wieder Materialprobleme die
Bundeswehr ist sowas ja wie die Ludolfs
unter den Armenien die hantiert mit
Schrott also ich habe mit meinem Rücken
noch ein paar Pausenbrote vom letzten
Schuljahr die kann ich der Bundeswehr
als Bio war verschwenden
als NATO Mitglied hat Deutschland
eigentlich zugesagt 2% seiner
Wirtschaftsleistung in Rüstung zu
investieren aber hey egal wir soll uns
werden
haben mich zum Lachen gebracht mit
putins-ukraine Invasion ändert sich
alles unser Kanzler Olaf ich bin die
Merkel nur mit Glatze Scholz verkündet
eine Zeitenwende und haut 100 Milliarden
Euro Sondervermögen raus Problem es gibt
null Plan wie man das Geld sinnvoll
einsetzen kann und so stehen wir heute
mit einer Amida bei der die Ausrüstung
genauso ramponiert ist wie das Image ich
wünsche mir auf jeden Fall mehr
Wertschätzung dass man auch auf der
Straße einfach mal angesprochen wird Tag
Soldat danke für den Dienst dass das
würde mein Herz
erwerben viel wichtiger ist doch für
unsere Truppe wie hat das diese berühmte
militärstrategien gesagt
dass sie eine Regierung haben die Ihnen
mehr gibt als nur sonntags ein paar
Worte warme ein paar Worte warme Worte
und dass wir jetzt wirklich brauchen
sind freiwilliger die uns im Fall der
Fälle heldenhaft verteidigen aber ja wer
sollte das sein
ihr Lieben das sollte mal reichen bitte
unterschreib doch auf den Zettel vor
euch noch dass ihr hier wird und dann
dürfte Vertrag für den Eintritt in die
Bundeswehr
was da habe ich ganz eventuell in das
falsche Fach gegriffen einfach
unterschreiben
okay tschüss schönes Leben noch aber
beschwert euch nicht bei mir wenn der
große vor der Tür steht oder der
Nordkoreaner oder der Niederländer das
ist eine sehr unterschätzte Gefahr hier
und dann mein Vaterlandsverräter
so apropos Freiwilligkeit hier sind noch
ein paar sehr gute Filme die euch
angucken könnt und das ist ein Befehl
ein freiwilliger Befehl das ist eine
befohlene Freiwilligkeit das ist egal
schaut es euch einfach an hier jetzt